I have video for you today
of two guys who are really confident
that they know a lot of different things
and that they are right about whatever
it is they choose to talk about I'm
talking about Bill Maher and NFL
quarterback Aaron Rodgers now this is a
clip from uh I believe this is Bill
Maher's newish podcast
and to be very clear
I think Aaron Rodgers is not a bright
guy and he said a lot of really wacky
things about covid and other things and
I also find his entire world view
completely uninteresting Bill Maher on
the other hand sometimes does say things
that I find uh prescient and compelling
and accurate but also Bill Maher
particularly when it comes to medical
stuff like I remember when I was this is
a really long time ago I remember an
episode of Bill Maher being interviewed
by Larry King the late Larry King and
Bill Maher took a position against
aspirin by saying why would you take
aspirin your body is not in an aspirin
deficient state so why would aspirin
ever be the thing to take which kind of
misunderstands medication completely so
he's always been a little weird on on
medical stuff regardless here is a clip
of Bill Maher and Aaron Rodgers
repeating some of the most tired lines
about science sometimes is wrong
medicine sometimes is wrong so therefore
you know the coveted conspiracy
theorists should have been listened to
just as much as everybody else let's
jump right into this first clip that's
my problem with with society today is
why does everything have to be so
bipartisan okay now right first of all
Aaron Rodgers means partisan
he doesn't even know what he's talking
about he doesn't mean why do things have
to be bipartisan he means why do things
have to be partisan like every issue is
not a partisan issue there's right and
there's wrong there's things that make
sense and things that don't make sense
toe the line on what your party's saying
to you know and that's the only stance
you can take right can you not
rationally have a conversation about
things that make sense and be able to to
not be swayed by whether you vote red or
blue not in America anymore no you can't
and and the ultimate to me the ultimate
issue that should not be political or
partisan is medicine Health yeah what is
more personal
then what I you know you do you to how
you want to uh treat your body now if
the argument is well if you don't do our
pharmaceutical answer then you're going
to uh risk other people's lives first of
all
that's not true that's a red herring
argument well sometimes it's true and
sometimes it's not but it doesn't
actually relate to the bigger issue that
they're building to so this this really
is hard to follow because it's such a
mishmash of different issues there's
whether science becomes partisan and of
course I mean look at what's going on
with climate science one side just
denies the science so so you've got that
issue you then have issues of Public
Health you have issues with bodily
autonomy and they're just mixing
everything together with a big dose of
confidence and what comes out is total
nonsense you know maybe
that's true with other things at other
times or with this before they knew that
the vaccine does not prevent infection
and does not prevent transferral so now
that we know it doesn't do either one of
those things
it shouldn't matter what I do so again
if you really want to have a nuanced
conversation this is not accurate and
I'm the first to tell you that there is
this very big period in the sort of meat
of the pandemic at which point the
variants that were floating around in
public were predominantly not variants
that were well handled by the original
vaccines in terms of infection that's
absolutely true very early on the first
when the first vaccines came out and you
still had a variant out there that was
much more similar to the original
variant for which the vaccines were
tailored the ability to prevent
infection was very high and if you're
not infected you don't have anything to
transmit that was the case early on as
the variance diverged from the original
more and more the vaccine's ability to
prevent infection and therefore
transmission declined and that's
absolutely true
we now have this new vaccine that is
tailored to Omicron and it seems
although we still need more data that
the ability of That vaccine to prevent
infection is higher and of course if you
don't have an infection you don't have
anything to transmit so the overarching
broad statements about this don't really
help anybody but they're determined to
moralize about it and so they have to
make such black and white statements
okay so that's first
but beyond that
what could be more personal than how I
choose to treat my body I mean like
Djokovic can't play
it's it's so annoying to me I'm watching
the US Open now yeah last night Serena
oh I didn't see she won she lost last
night oh
oh well but the best player in the men's
side can't play
and one of the most fit guys in the
[ __ ] world
at least once if not twice it's
it is it come to New York is a complete
compendium of what a potemkin village
this whole
arsenal of nonsense they've thrown at
this disease is you know what's even
worse than that though Kyrie Irving
attended a basketball game
Courtside but couldn't play for his team
right
are you how is that possible well also
he attended a basketball game
and got to watch it in the stands but
couldn't play on his team because he
wasn't maxed so understand that this is
this is basically outrage porn because
if you sit down and you go so what
exactly is the point you're making is
the point you're making that science is
sometimes wrong well science by its
nature is a self-correcting process and
figuring out where you were wrong is
actually revered and it's a good thing
so that's not really breaking news is
your argument that corporations don't
have the right legally to require
vaccination because they do and so it's
just a mishmash of stuff it's sort of
Herschel Walker like in a way more
coherent to just make people mad but
it's not exactly completely clear what
they mean let's just look at one more
clip from this to me the frightening
thing was never the disease itself the
frightening thing was how much you could
you could get people so quickly to
change their way of life stay home wear
a mask
you know don't don't as altruistic at
first it's like oh yeah yeah take two
weeks to flatten the curve right and
then
just about well every conspiracy theory
came true vaccine mandates vaccine
passport Now understand this is again
more outrage sewing more fear what does
it mean that a conspiracy theory came
true because there were vaccine mandates
we've had vaccine requirements in the
United States going back at least to
1903 out of Cambridge Massachusetts if
not even be I believe Washington's Army
right so it it's not a what does it mean
that it's a conspiracy theory that there
were going to be vaccine mandates we
have all sorts of vaccine requirements
what does that even mean but people hear
it and they go that's right Aaron
Rodgers is right and I should be furious
right and it turned into like away from
doing your job to stop the the spread to
like lockdowns and that's my whole
problem
you know by the way remember the the
nobody was locked down in the United
States it's an absurd statement to use
now they'll go well it was effectively a
lockdown because when everything's
closed
but most stuff didn't close it there was
there was no lockdown I grew up in a
small town with very little cases up in
Chico California but all the small
businesses [ __ ] gone I mean our
favorite restaurants in LA and New York
and across the country not just in big
cities but some crazy percentage will
never open again yeah and of course
that's absolutely true and I think there
are many criticisms Fair criticisms to
make about how covet was handled there's
no problem with that but these
mishmashes of so-called open and
unfettered conversation
they're obviously these are perfectly
fine not saying that anybody should be
censored but they just make people angry
without even knowing what they're angry
about and that is exactly the way that
this stuff works uh remember that on 919
Monday morning we'll be doing the next
David Pacman show one day membership
special get on my mailing list at
davidpackman.com to be notified of how
to sign up
imagine this scenario you try logging
into your email account to see that your
password was changed a few hours ago
except you didn't do it and then you get
notifications of activity from your bank
and from your credit cards but you
didn't do any of it that is what
identity theft is like it can happen
very quickly and if you don't act fast
it can get worse we've dealt with this
at the David Pacman show you can find
videos about it and that's why I protect
myself now using Aura our sponsor Aura
is Identity Theft Protection fraud
monitoring password management and an
antivirus all in one easy to use app
Aura will monitor the dark web for your
emails passwords and Social Security
numbers and we'll send you alerts
quickly to your phone and email Aura
also gives you near real-time alerts on
suspicious credit inquiries like if
someone was opening a loan or a credit
card in your name and if you sign up at
aura.com Pacman you will get a free
two-week trial which you can use to see
if your login credentials have been
leaked online I would want to know that
right away use the link below